sie haben wir vergessen nicht zu hause
und alle sind in stuttgart außer ich
also folgende situation
ich habe das gerade zweimal aufgenommen
alle sind in stuttgart außer ich bei so
einem browser gegen alle ding und sie
werden heute einfach apache live sehen
und das ist so mein traum seit monaten
ich habe einfach verpennt bzw habe ich
gedacht das was anderes ist und dann
hatte ich keine lust dann hab ich jetzt
am ende geschenk was es sein soll
und da war sie jetzt auch quasi
theoretisch zu spät schon beinahe hätte
sie auch geschafft aber ich musste auch
noch den block schneiden für heute also
wäre das alles ein bisschen komisch
geworden deswegen habe ich jetzt nicht
gemacht und ich bin eigentlich ganz froh
weil endlich habe ich die kohle für mich
alleine
und heute kann ich endlich alles machen
was ich ein kleines wohnung schon immer
mal machen wollte wie mir gerade gar
nicht so sicher was ist eigentlich ist
aber ich habe nicht die tür zugemacht
als ich auf kuba
ich habe die behörde benutzen
woher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sonst von apache 27 werden von spotify
nachgespielt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich muss auf jeden fall einkaufen gehen
ich habe keine zeit haben ja ja dieses
alleinsein es irgendwie doch nicht so
gail kelly ich lass einfach meine
klamotten auf dem boden liegen
danke also was hat sie denn hier als
kind
laut absorb usa
das soll jetzt gut absorbiert arias
secret very sexy olala laura mit noise
treysa das riecht irgendwie café ich
hoffe das war nicht teuer
heute ist mir egal ich benutzt ein
komisches torres
[Musik]
kelly ich trinke ein glas champagner ja
gross leute aber einen schönen tag in
köln
willkommen in meinem kleiderschrank
du annika ja kelly dann fang mal wieder
nach australien wann immer du willst
kelly
[Musik]
ob du annika ja kelly dann fangen wir
mal wieder zu 1live krone
wann immer du willst
[Musik]
so ich habe mich jetzt geschminkt und
ein bisschen beruhigt ich weiß dass ich
jetzt alleine bin und einfach alles
die frage ist jetzt nur was mache ich
frage jetzt einfach meine follower auf
instagram hey leute ich bin heute
alleine in köln was kann ich alleine
machen folgt instagram eigenen ziemlich
gratis make up gemacht aber irgendwie
sieht man das jetzt nicht mehr so kommen
könnte kellys wäsche bügeln
ich hasse es mich elizabeth ii also
person nicht kennen gelernt hat die
wirklich ihre wäsche gebügelt als es
macht viel sinn weil immer wenn ich das
anziehen möchte was mich gebügelt ist
rege ich mich voll laufen muss dann
bügeln
aber sie bügelt ist bevor sie sind
schrank legt vorbildliches kind meine
kinder theoretisch könnte ich eigentlich
kellys wohnungen weihnachtlich
dekorieren
dafür müsste ich aber noch mal in die
stadt schon wieder aber weihnachtsdeko
ist so teuer
ich habe aber auch das gefühl dass
seitlich lok müsse mache ist mir so das
vollkommen egal ob er mich ungeschminkt
sehen von welchem winkel ihr mich seht
ob ich doppelt in manchen situationen
habe ich finde das so unglaublich
menschlich dass ich das mega feiern
ich habe dich brocken mensch zu sein und
nicht mehr so wiederholen abgesehen
menschen achten jetzt voll auf giulia
bei männern bei mir ist doch nicht so ja
da bin ich mal ein tag alleine mir und
ich mache mir gedanken
ich schaue gerade den song chris mit
den bewegungs bzw nur mit dennis und dem
wildcard gewinner hat alcoa gut ich
dabei gut es ist wirklich lustig dieses
video ist eile auf dem aber ihr müsst
heute unbedingt anschauen vielleicht und
übersee passieren wird
so komme ich weiß nicht wie die heizung
funktioniert und das ist so variieren
die läufer noch ist nach hause kommt ich
mache die heizung immer heiß sagt ich
muss jetzt kadi anrufen eigentlich dumme
im winter einen job zu machen weil die
haare halten ein ja gut von der kälte
weg und somit dem zoff macht man wieder
alles auf ich habe doch jemand
natürliches fällen klar wie gehts wie
sie stuttgart bei dem boot angekommen
scheint also ich hab ein frage und zwar
freiwillig sein badezimmer jetzt auf 27
grad gemacht okay ich bin ich gar nicht
mehr darauf 27 grad
gerade bei 27 grad
ja ich könnte jetzt doch unseres
untergestellt hast ja ich weiß manchmal
zunahme was anderes gedrückt und dann
ist plötzlich der rollladen runter
gegangen
timo ich jetzt angerufen der auch keine
lust mit mir zu sprechen lok ist seit
fast einer stunde online von keiner
schaut sich den an
superklasse dafür mache ich doch gerne
content vielleicht denken die leute dass
es der livestream ist und deswegen
klicken wenn ich auf das video
weil sie das wahrscheinlich schon im
livestream gesehen
aber keine heilung gibt es ja weil
gestern wahrscheinlich wären das dann
gesehen und ich hab's mir selber versaut
ja der strecke eines youtube ist oder
sag ich mal ist hier ganz schnell war
dieser stelle in den block zu
ich gucke ich habe jetzt mal was ihr mir
auf instagram vorgeschlagen habt jetzt
müssen zwei vergangen
schaut mal was kino geschrieben hat was
soll ich alleine in köln machen super
set kurian barbecue
nein ich war am sonntag in einem kombi
ein barbecue laden hier in köln war der
war gut
ich liebe es wenn man auch instagram
eine frage gestellt dass die leute dann
wirklich gerne gerne gerne gerne gerne
gerne gerne gerne gerne antworten
schokoladenmuseum gehen die
wohngemeinschaft oder können den veganen
castella self care day habe ich schon
mit dem champagner gemacht harry potter
1 7000 2002 gucken ins kino gehen
rosenzweig gucken lecker essen es gibt
mega gute social und auch gute
politische sushi haben hier heute auch
los kölner zoo china life festival das
china life festival also das wollen sich
aber ganz schön viele leute mit mir
treffen das finde ich ja schon mal ganz
fantastisch dass china life festival
lässt den kölner zu und die tierwelt im
lichterglanz erstrahlen sechs wochen
lang 100 leuchtende tiere und
fantasiefiguren den zu und erinnern an
dessen 160-jährigen geschichte
ich weiß was ich mache ich werde jetzt
in die innenstadt fahren weihnachtsdeko
kaufen und kellys wohnung dekorieren
darauf habe ich auf allermeisten los
dabei mache ich mir dann später noch
einen film an
trinkt noch vielleicht ein glas
champagner und dann gehe ich auch schön
gemütlich ins bett schneit morgen vor
den block formiert superklasse was sagt
ihr dazu
vielleicht setze ich mich noch in der
bar wenn ich das noch nie gemacht habe
ich habe mich noch nie allein
wohin gesetzt ich mache jetzt ich gehe
jetzt aus der haustür jetzt
[Musik]
am back ich war alleine in köln
unterwegs und habe ordentlich was
eingekauft willkommen bei meinem kleinen
und bescheidenen christmas i
ich war wirklich überall einkaufen womit
fangen wir an wir fahren mit dm an oder
und ist in meinem rucksack bei dm habe
ich gekauft einmal diesen süßen kleinen
tannenbaum den ich auch schon für meine
wohnung geholt haben einander nahe und
so ein richtig schöner tillich behälter
ich glaube ich habe am ende auch einfach
sachen für kelly geholt die silber haben
möchte der hat vier euro 45 gekostet und
der tannenbaum 22 und ich war echt
überrascht weil ich nicht erwartet hätte
dass bei dm so schöne dji befinde
kommen wir zur nächsten kategorie und
zwar mit ihm habe ich noch was justin
kelly wird mich dafür liegen die story
dazu ich habe mir im herbst so ein
eichhörnchen für mein fenster gekauft
das ist mir richtig hier ein wander und
ich mir gekommen also ich glaube ich
mache auch hauptsächlich ein
schlafzimmer makeover das wird sie dann
halt auch noch richtig sehen weil im
wohnzimmer ist so viel und so vielen
depot konnte ich nicht kaufen das er
viel zu viel
dann kommen wir jetzt zu backen erstmal
bin ich zu depot gelangen und bei depot
habe ich echt nichts gefunden bzw ja
schon sachen aber die wollte ich da für
mein geld nicht ausgeben und dann bin
ich zum butlers gegangen und dort habe
ich eine sache gefunden die mir gut
gefallen hat allgemein finde ich butlers
ist irgendwie besser als depot obwohl in
bad laasphe wenige leute waren als im
depot
ich weiß nicht irgendwie hat mir die
programm nicht zugesagt naja und im
butlers habe ich das 1 meter 85 ist sehr
groß 13 euro decke kostet für 13 euro
kann man sich drehen weil depot schießen
und das ist wirklich ein schöner großer
kranz den habe ich nirgendwo gesehen
ich bin nicht ganz sicher durch den hier
im schlafzimmer anbringen kann
ich kann sie halt jetzt nicht anrufen
und fragen wo ihre weihnachts deko ist
ich würde so gerne ihre wohnung mit
ihrem zeug halt einfach kräftig um ihren
aber ich weiß nicht wo ihre deko ist
keine ahnung
die frisch umgezogen ich würde das
glaube ich nicht mehr der alten wohnung
dann war ich bei samy flower design
es waren super süßer blumenladen erst
klaue art ist ja super sympathischer typ
hat mir mut sachen verkaufen können weil
ich eigentlich nicht so viele kaufleute
und dann am ende habe ich doch gekauft
zuallererst können wir darüber reden wie
wunderschön die ist wow christbaumkugel
nummer eins und dies so groß seht ihr
das griffbrett kugel nummer dorf auch
beautiful barry kitschig aber auch
wieder riesig und diese zeit hat mich
auch ich leben davon
und auch wieder riesengroß wunderschön
und die fragen
insgesamt haben 63 euro bei dem bezahlt
ich glaube die haben so fünf euro das
stück gekostet
dann hab ich noch richtig übertrieben
aber ich kannte ihn so schön und ich
wusste nicht ob du kannst also da
schlägt echt mein mann an der herz höher
machtvoll direkt hier und trinken jungen
gute kerzen natur kerzen jo wieder
verwendbar und schön
ich weiß aber auch wieder nicht ob ich
mir eigentlich ein kranz gewünscht habe
oder ob ich hier wirklich einchecken
wollte der kann sind übrigens 38 euro
gekostet das war auch so kommen wir
jetzt zum teuersten laden also 20
betreuer zu laden ist ein
antiquitätenladen der erste bei dem ich
war
und da habe ich diese christbaumkugel
die habe ich für mich besorgt die finde
ich sehr schön ich weiß nicht mal warum
und ich weiß auch nicht genau ob die
würden ein bis toll bei kelly jetzt am
bett links und rechts passen sind für
mich aus thun sind im strom verbunden
wie gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
toll warum denke ich mir immer so sachen
für kelly aus wo ich keine ahnung
hey brenke kelly und dekoriere ihre
wohnung dieses richtigkeit wohl diese
wohnung so war bis schlafen ich sage
jetzt eine stunde auf dem sofa diesen
sound clash gesehen und es tut mir leid
und erfuhr dass ich nichts dazu gesagt
habe ich werde nachhinein doch gerne
hingegangen weil ich einfach gerne auch
budget ich bleibe einfach nur so liegen
dass kelly augen kommt ist mir egal ob
ich war hunger
ich traue ich mich mal was essen zu
gehen
weißt du ich ja auch um zu meckern
und jetzt das was ich tun wollte
[Musik]
haus nummer 1 gut so ich dachte ich hier
für den mac die wird so ein schlechter
traum kommt oder das einfach so gelernt
murg ist angebracht
so jetzt kommt aber eigentlich das
worauf ich mich am allermeisten gefreut
habe kelly bekommt in der ganzen wohnung
fenster sticker dieser hund muss dann
hin
mann ich hätte noch mehr kaufen sollen
hier wird nicht so aus sie wird mich so
einzige haben wir noch könnt ihr diesen
spiegel der iss aus harry potter
das ist die lieblings spiegel wisst ihr
was dann perfekt drauf hast du denn ich
habe einfach harry potter des respektes
wird
klein christmas häuser hier ist der
kranz ich hab kein teller gefunden
deswegen muss er noch so auf dem papier
liegen
und hier ist das ding ich muss mir so
war es ruhig um irgendwie voll kaputt
von kommt eine krankheit oder so ich
glaube ich sage ja schon gutes kann sein
dass ich mich nochmal behälter aber
ansonsten gute nacht oder guten morgen
guten mittag oder guten abend wir sehen
uns dann morgen wieder okay
[Musik]